angry residents of the el bosque
community in santiago had begun by
blocking streets and screaming who are
hungry
riot police tried to dispel the crowd
with water cannon in teargas but they
refused to budge and responded with
rocks and sticks seems reminiscent of
the social upheaval that rocked Chile
for months until the corona virus
pandemic saw the pause button hit on
protests el bosque is a poor and
overcrowded municipality where the
majority struggled to make enough to
survive even before they were ordered
into total quarantine in mid-april a
full month before the entire capital was
locked down on Friday people say they're
not against the quarantine just
starvation just get out of here yelled
this woman at police this was exactly
what many predicted might happen in the
face of widespread unemployment and
growing hardships brought on by
confinement and a deepening recession
the night before president service Leon
Panetta had announced a plan to
distribute 2.5 million boxes of food and
cleaning products for the needy across
the country less than 24 hours later he
rushed to address the nation again
appealing for patience and understanding
sindhu execute the process of preparing
and distributing these boxes demands a
tremendous logistical effort and needs
some time we understand the urgency for
many so we are working tirelessly to
start distribution by the end of this
week or the beginning of next week but
for tens of thousands of Chileans who
have been left with nothing next week
may seem like a lifetime away this
latest protest shows that many Chileans
have already run out of patience and the
biggest fear is that this incident could
well snowball into far more widespread
protests
that could be even more difficult to
control the in Chile's earlier social
explosion you see in human al Jazeera
Santiago